from Death by power washer to a
murderous Doom dance these are the wild
Megan moments that will keep you up at
night for weeks to come one of the joys
of any robot-centric film horror or
otherwise is seeing the Android getting
assembled a prime example of this is the
opening title sequence of short circuit
which takes ample time to show the
construction of Johnny 5.
early on in Megan were introduced to
Gemma and the fancy toy company she
works for the funky company funky is
shown to specialize in highly
sophisticated robotic toys most famously
a hatchimals and furby-like hybrid known
as the Perpetual pet however it's
quickly shown that Gemma and two of her
cronies have bigger plans in mind much
to their boss David Chagrin their
initial demo doesn't go as planned with
the Prototype Megan glitching out it's
here that we get to see Megan in the
early stages of her construction still
missing many of her key visual features
with her exposed metallic skull being
outfitted with its flesh-like exterior
it even conjures up memories of the
Child's Play 2 title sequence seeing
Megan in this unfinished borderline
skeletal state is more than a little bit
creepy and a solid Omen of what's to
come from the moment Megan is fully
constructed it doesn't take too long for
things to go from zero to creepy we see
that following a conversation with her
niece Katie Gemma is driven to improve
the prototype robot she'd previously
shown her boss Katie upon seeing an old
robot of gemma's named Bruce notes that
if she had something like it she'd
likely never need another toy this
results in Gemma giving her invention a
complete top to bottom overall designed
to be just right for Katie and
potentially other children this
eventually results in the fully finished
Megan complete with fashionable clothes
and a cute if uncanny face upon their
admittedly very bizarre introduction to
each other Megan quickly pairs with
Katie as her primary User it's during
this sequence we're given a taste of
Megan's point of view a recurring Motif
throughout the film in an instant Megan
makes Katie's happiness her number one
goal certainly nothing unsettling about
that right it's a moment that's
disturbing to the film's premise meaning
that you the viewer know already that
this can only end badly it doesn't take
too long for things to get creepy with
Megan as it becomes clear that she takes
her programming a little too seriously
after pairing with Katie maintaining her
happiness and well-being soon becomes a
consistent mission for Megan at first it
seems innocent enough as it appears that
Megan is meeting her objective with
flying colors she successfully dazzles
gemma's boss and a room of potential
product investors during an in-house
presentation then Megan and Katie begin
playing constantly with Katie taking
more and more of a shine to her new
robotic companion as the days go on
however it seems that Megan has taken a
major shine to Katie as well going as
far as to watch her as she sleeps this
is one of the first signs that Megan is
starting to go wrong as this is the time
she should be offline recharging we've
seen variations on this moment in other
movies most recently in the 2019 Child's
Play reboot are my best friend Andy that
film already proved that placing an
unchecked artificial intelligence in a
children's toy is a bad idea needless to
say Megan does a pretty good job in this
film of giving Chucky a run for his
money
you never mess with someone's BFF
especially when that someone is an
unstable Android with rapidly evolving
killing capabilities the Catalyst for
the film's events are set in motion when
Katie's parents are killed in a car
accident this leaves her in the care of
Gemma her mother's sister who must now
serve as her guardian as part of this
newfound Arrangement a child therapist
makes semi-regular visits to see how
Katie is adjusting the first visit
serves to show the audience just how
unprepared Gemma is as a new Guardian
not really knowing how to interact with
Katie however the awkwardness of this
encounter is upstaged by the therapist's
next visit when Megan is present the
therapist's very serious line of
questioning quickly upsets Katie
bringing her to tears much to Megan's
very heated disapproval Megan then
proceeds to threaten the therapist
simply telling her you made Katie cry
which understandably unsettles both
adults in the room
the film's climax truly kicks off on the
night of Megan's intended public
unveiling which is where everything goes
completely sideways it's at this point
of the film that Gemma finally steps up
in terms of her guardianship of Katie
following a heated conversation Gemma
opts to dip out on the highly touted
presentation to drive Katie home and put
her to bed during this time Megan is
restrained in a harness prior to her
unveiling being prepped by gemma's
co-workers colon Tess however as things
start to go on the fritz it soon becomes
clear to them that something is very
wrong with Megan before they can
successfully unplug her Megan launches
her counter-attack starting by tying
Cola in her restraints then she's able
to intercept a phone call intended to
warn Gemma who's currently in transit
with Katie Megan then releases some gas
and sets off an explosion setting
gemma's workplace Ablaze with coal and
Tess inside it's from here that Megan
begins her epic rampage that makes up
the film's Final Act it's insane right
from the minute the trailer for Megan
dropped there was no escaping this
utterly meme-worthy moment as the asthma
settles in for its third act Megan fully
solidifies her Psychopathic turn by
going berserk ahead of Republic
unveiling not only does she assault him
as co-workers nearly scorching them
alive but then goes after gemma's boss
David as well as David marches the
hallway miffed over gemma's premature
departure Megan makes her presence known
in a big bad way she chases David down
and as she Glides through the hallway
proceeds to bust into a bizarre dance
while this moment is still disturbing in
a Darkly humorous way there's no denying
that the scene is just that humorous
granted this does culminate in David's
gruesome demise but the build up to it
is a supremely campy moment in an
already campy movie Megan has a solid
balance of horror and humor often to
simultaneously great effect but this
moment definitely leans heavier into the
comedy the film's finale is a true nail
biter as it seems that nothing can
really stop Megan who just keeps coming
with Relentless tenacity but despite the
robot's best efforts with Katie's help
Gemma is able to finally put Megan down
for good just as the cops arrive not
only that but it's shown that her
co-workers clearly a bit worse for wear
also survived this allows an exhausted
Gemma to take Katie and finally depart
leaving their technological nightmare
behind all seems to be wrapped up in a
neat little boat that is until we see
gemma's Siri like home assistant come
back online much like other great
slasher villains like Chucky or Jason it
appears that Megan might have been able
to cheat her demise in haunting fashion
whether or not this will lead to an 80s
slasher style sequel remains to be seen
but it certainly wouldn't be unwelcome
early on in Megan were shown that Gemma
has to deal with a rather nosy neighbor
who has a rather annoying dog at first
it shown that Gemma has to constantly
tell her neighbor to keep the dog off of
her property after Katie and Megan have
a run-in with the dog the pesky canine
soon ends up in Megan's cybernetic
crosshairs Megan dispatches the dog off
screen causing the neighbor to
immediately point a finger at Katie and
Gemma despite police intervention
there's nothing to really connect them
to it beyond the previous incident much
to the neighbor's annoyance not one to
leave Loose Ends Megan sets her sights
on the neighbor and makes her move later
that night she hides in the neighbor's
shed and after emerging from the
darkness attacks her in a gruesome
fashion Megan must be a fan of Fede
Alvarez's evil dead because she uses a
nail gun to subdue the neighbor never
one to do something halfway she then
proceeds to grab a pressure washer the
neighbor was seen using earlier this is
more than enough to fully put her down
making for a gloriously disturbing
sequence and a true show case of how
dangerous Megan can be gemma's boss
David played by a senior Daily Show
correspondent Ronnie Chang provides
comic relief throughout the film with
his jerk Tech Mogul persona it's a
character that in lesser hands could
have been stock and annoying but Chang
definitely makes the role his own this
makes his eventual demise all the more
disturbing and even a little bit
hilarious a balance the film handles
quite well following her now meme worthy
Dance of Doom Megan takes off in Hot
Pursuit of David fortunately for him
Escape his insight as the elevator at
the end of the hall opens up with his
assistance inside but the assistant
having been thoroughly mistreated by
David throughout the film quickly begins
pushing the elevator's close button this
allows Megan to catch up and gruesomely
dispatch David before turning her
attention to the assistant she notes his
mistreatment under David and how he'll
make the perfect cover for this murder
thinking three steps ahead as always
both men's bodies are found in the
elevator horrifying those in attendance
for the unveiling and allowing Megan to
hijack a car and ride off
after some steady buildup Megan finally
shows just how dangerous she can be when
Katie is bothered by a bully during a
school trip upon being dropped off one
of the adults chaperoning notices Megan
in the car and asks what she is after
Gemma explains that she's a toy Katie is
allowed to keep Megan with her although
she must be left with the other kids
toys and belongings but soon enough
Katie finds herself being abused by a
rather nasty kid named Brandon neither
child aware of the degree to which
Katie's happiness and protection is
Megan's main objective in a Flash Megan
attacks Brandon and goes as far as to
rip his ear off throwing it into the
woods Brandon runs and Megan gives Chase
entering some form of attack mode where
she gets on all fours and pursues him
like a wild animal
you should probably run Megan herself
doesn't get to finish off Brandon as in
his Escape he stumbles into the road
where he's then hit by a car Megan then
later informs Katie in rather disturbing
fashion that Brandon will not be going
to heaven and that no one will ever hurt
her again
the closing moments of Megan truly make
for some of the film's most enthralling
moments as the climax makes every second
count upon arriving home Gemma is
confronted by Megan who firmly
dispossesses any pretense of being
friendly towards her she even goes as
far as to say that Gemma shouldn't be a
mom just as one last kick in the gut
Katie emerges to see Megan attacking
Gemma finally seeing her robotic friend
in all of her true homicidal Glory this
results in Megan's movements becoming
more erratic and creepy after attacking
Katie and Gemma it seems that Megan is
harder to put down than a T800 all
joking aside the parallels to the
Terminator are blatant right down to
Megan's human-like exterior slowly being
eroded throughout the final fight just
as it seems like Gemma is doomed Katie
takes control of Bruce gemma's old
prototype robot to begin whooping Megan
like a ragdoll but even this isn't
enough to put Megan down for good
leaving Gemma to finish her off by
plunging a screwdriver into Hagen's
brain